vous pourriez vous présenter
je m'appelle docking oui j'ai lancé le
national book et si vous disiez je suis
celui qui a changé la comédie pour
toujours mais je n'ai pas réussi à me
changer moi oui on s'en remettra au
genou on pourra le mettre tout ce qu'on
voudra même des black cats qui l'a
d'attac tulle un mois moti vite moi qui
fais pas le journal on la garde pour le
premier numéro c'est un échec total
on vend même pas la moitié du tirage
tu vas pas lui faire de mal non qu'est
ce que tu fais peut-être pas je crois
pas qu'il soit chargé tease
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mormons protestent les féministes
nous détestent le qu'est-ce qu'on l'a
fait aux catholiques lie 5000 lits on
est poursuivi en justice par disney
c'était peut-être pas si génial comme
idée ni ni qui déballe ses seins on lui
a mis des caches tu es tu au concret la
femme que vous draguez doux kenny chat
in full swing en direct
on a déjà du mal à sortir un magazine on
a qu'à voir du mal à faire autre chose
pour le premier film nationals pour les
filles
giorgi laser doute qinshan et il faut
soit yoga l'un des auteurs se trouve
ainsi qu un prétexte pour faire la fête
vous avez ruiné cette boîte je peux pas
revenir comme un raté j'ai le souci
sincèrement de doit briller bon
voir quelqu'un rapidement dans le mât
villon sur votre droite
quelques uns des créateurs d' american
college travail sur leur prochain film
et je parie que ce sera tout aussi
délirant d'où il faut qu'on décide c'est
clair là qu'il est en train de se
branler où je ne fais plus bas au plus
haut en fonction de la taille de mon
d'armes
on ne peut pas dire que ces acteurs
soient les sosies des vraies mais enfin
vous croyez que je ressemblais à will
forte quand j'avais 27 ans vous croyez
vraiment que will forte à 27 ans
aller malgré le fait pour le journal as
[Musique]